vamos a ver con más detalle lo que
sucede a largo plazo en un mercado de
competencia perfecta lo que tenemos del
lado izquierdo que ya hemos visto varias
veces son las curvas de oferta y demanda
para un mercado de competencia perfecta
podemos ver el precio de equilibrio
señalado con esta línea punteada y como
lo hemos mencionado ya en varios vídeos
las empresas en un mercado de
competencia perfecta las empresas en
competencia perfecta tienen que ser
precio aceptantes por lo que el precio
de mercado va a ser su curva de ingreso
marginal que es esta curva horizontal y
algo razonable para ellas es producir
cierta cantidad no van a determinar el
precio pero si pueden elegir qué
cantidad producir y lo razonable es
seguir produciendo mientras que el
ingreso marginal sea mayor que el costo
marginal para esta empresa en esta
situación es razonable producir esta
cantidad y como hemos mencionado en
otros vídeos hasta esta cantidad la
empresa tendrá una ganancia económica y
la forma en la que podemos ver esto es
en esta cantidad este
es el costo total promedio esto es el
ingreso marginal por lo que se tendrá
todo esto por unidad la altura es cuánto
se obtiene por unidad y lo multiplicamos
por el número de unidades de manera que
el área de este rectángulo es la
ganancia económica positiva que tendrá
esta empresa todo esto es a corto plazo
pero ahora pensemos en qué es lo que
pasará a largo plazo si las personas se
dan cuenta de que otras personas están
teniendo una ganancia económica positiva
recuerden que la ganancia económica no
solo toma en cuenta el costo regular
sino que también incluye el costo de
oportunidad las otras personas dirán oye
yo también quiero poner mis recursos en
este mercado para tener ganancias
económicas pero qué pasará si tenemos
más nuevos participantes en este mercado
pues la curva de oferta se va a
desplazar a la derecha una forma de
pensar en esto es que para cualquier
precio dado habrá más oferta esta es la
curva de oferta 1 ahora tendremos más
participantes
qué va a pasar pues es posible tener una
situación como esta al tener más
participantes ahora tenemos la curva de
oferta 2 ahora cuál será la cantidad que
tenga que producir la empresa y
recuerden que en esta situación la
empresa a es sólo una de muchas empresas
pues en esta situación tenemos un nuevo
precio de equilibrio este es peso 1 y
ahora tenemos este nuevo precio de
equilibrio peso 2 lo que va a determinar
una nueva curva de ingreso marginal para
todos los involucrados en este mercado
de competencia perfecta por lo que la
nueva curva de ingreso marginal va a
estar aquí en esta situación cuál será
la cantidad razonable que la empresa a
debe producir nuevamente siempre que el
ingreso marginal sea mayor que el costo
marginal tiene sentido que ellos
produzcan cada vez más hasta llegar al
punto en donde son iguales el ingreso
marginal y el costo marginal por lo que
ahora la empresa querrá producir menos
cantidad debido a que el precio del
mercado que tiene que tomar es menor
noten qué es lo que sucede cada vez más
participantes llegaron al mercado el
precio de mercado que también define la
curva horizontal del ingreso marginal
bajó más hasta el punto en el que la
empresa en esta situación no tiene
ganancia económica en este punto no
solamente el ingreso marginal intersec a
al costo marginal sino que es
exactamente el mismo punto en el que el
costo marginal iguala al costo total
promedio una forma de pensar en esto es
que una empresa en competencia perfecta
tiene eficiencia productiva si están
produciendo la cantidad que minimiza su
costo total promedio ya hemos hablado de
este punto en donde el costo marginal y
el costo total promedio se intersectan
este será el punto mínimo para el costo
total promedio a qué se debe esto bueno
mientras el costo marginal esté por
debajo del costo total promedio el costo
total promedio disminuirá cada vez más y
cuando el costo marginal comience a ser
mayor que el costo total promedio
entonces la curva del costo total
promedio va a incrementar
acabamos de ver una situación en la que
cuando hay ganancia económica en el
corto plazo los nuevos participantes en
búsqueda de esa ganancia a largo plazo
van a reducir esa ganancia económica
hasta cero y en ese punto donde la
empresa no tiene ganancia económica
tendrá eficiencia productiva producen en
el punto mínimo de su curva del costo
total promedio ya hemos mencionado antes
que este punto de equilibrio en el
mercado debido a la intersección de las
curvas de oferta y demanda es donde se
definen el precio y la cantidad de
equilibrio y donde también es eficiente
la asignación de recursos ya hemos
hablado de la pérdida de eficiencia en
la asignación de los recursos que no es
lo que está ocurriendo acá la ganancia
marginal es igual al costo marginal
justo en este punto donde están el
precio y la cantidad de equilibrio quizá
algunos de ustedes digan bueno y qué hay
de las otras situaciones qué pasa si por
alguna razón la gente comienza a entrar
de más y hay demasiada gente en el
mercado imaginemos la curva de oferta 3
va a pasar aquí permítanme etiquetarlo
esta es la curva de ingreso marginal 1
que es igual a p 1
esta es la curva de ingreso marginal 2
que es igual al precio 2 y para esta
nueva curva el precio de equilibrio
estará aquí precio 3 que define el
ingreso marginal 3 es igual al precio 3
si entran demasiados participantes a
este mercado ahora la empresa estará en
un escenario más difícil ahora tendrán
que producir esta cantidad de la que ya
hemos hablado muchas veces pero en esta
cantidad cada unidad tendrá un costo
total promedio que es mayor que el
ingreso marginal que obtienen por lo que
tendrán una pérdida económica a corto
plazo pero que sucederá a largo plazo a
largo plazo la empresa probablemente
salga del mercado así como otras
empresas que tengan pérdida económica
saldrán del mercado esto hará que se
desplace de vuelta a la izquierda la
curva de la oferta y eventualmente
regresaremos a esa realidad en donde las
empresas no tienen ganancia económica y
las empresas producen en él
mínimo de su curva de costo total
promedio que también se conoce como
eficiencia productiva